votre allié monsieur allenbach à
associer madame vigneault à la milice
vichyste tous les coups sont il permet
pour gagner écoutez là je crois que je
vais être très claire par rapport à cela
un monsieur à lembach a fait donc une
affiche
moi je les appelais personnellement je
vais demander qu'il la retire parce que
je pense que ça n'avait pas sa place
c'est pour ça qu'elle a été retirée dès
le lendemain dans la vitrine
je crois qu'il ya des comparaisons qui
n'ont pas lieu d'être donc voilà c'est
d'accord est clair mais c'est sa raison
du maintien il fait pas partie de ma
liste en tant que tel il vous demande
monsieur à l'oser pourquoi ne pas avoir
retiré votre candidature au profit de l
air avec le risque de l'extrême gauche
mais ça n'existe pas ce scénario où est
ce qu'on a vu à lyon oui alors sur les
cno rouge d'accord nos visions les
alliances et les rues mlrs ça existait
de 20% qui se retire mais ça ça n'existe
pas d'ailleurs ça n'a jamais existé
monsieur fargo a fait semblant une mise
en scène pour essayer de séduire les
électeurs qui avaient voté pour moi qui
sont pas très content d'ailleurs de son
de son attitude c'est assez peu assez
peu républicain encore aurait-il proposé
une fusion il avait opéré avec succès
mais ça n'a pas été le cas une façon nos
listes sont trop peu éloigné une fusion
vous auriez pu en disant au moins on
aurait été mis devant nos
responsabilités mais ça n'a même pas été
le cas c'était juste une n'avait pas
dégagé dégagé de l'espace et du mépris
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas ce que
jamais je n'aurais osé faire une telle
proposition
monsieur goût d'ailleurs nous listes
sont très proches et on va stresser pour
ça les choses pour ça que vous avez des
candidats actifs c'est le 5 août avec
ses candidats sur dix serait que si
fihri à la beauté pour nous et le niveau
des dons stratégie de campagne dont vous
voyez comme quoi il ya des prises de
responsabilité qu'ils répondent les
techniques de campagne quand vous ratez
le directeur ce qu'il s'agit de roy
quand anne vignot effectivement c'est
revenue régulièrement pendant la
campagne
etes-vous l'extrême gauche alors on
découvre de que depuis plus de 20 ans la
gauche est installée à besançon
toutes les gauches même le parti
communiste parce que en fait on va se
dire les choses
souvent c'est ce sont les communistes
qui sont visés et les communistes ils
ont participé au développement d'un
certain nombre de politiques
je tiens à revenir par exemple sur la
gestion de l'eau qui autour de ces
tables serait en capacité de dire qu'une
politique portée par des communistes à
besançon est une mauvaise politique
la preuve c'est que l'ensemble de la
communauté urbaine a opté le principe
d'aller sur c'est régis sur l'eau donc
on voit que le lien moment
et c'est nationale c'est pas à besançon
c'est un des éléments de langage qui
sont utilisés par en particulier les
républicains pour montrer qu dressée
comme la frange défi d'ouvrir la peau à
la france insoumis c'est pourquoi gougy
de vite faire d'autre sur quoi vous
basez le soir du premier tour madame
vigneault a été très clair en disant je
suis prête à travailler avec la france
insoumise sus un secret c'est un secret
de polichinelle aujourd'hui que vous
avez essayé de faire liste commune vous
n'y est pas arrivé vous êtes les deux
victoires on laisse répondre parce que
là vous la coincer dans le projet qu'on
lit la nature d'une lycéenne réalité les
lis qu'on a connus de gauche a besoin de
plus 60 ans n'aurait pas mis les
transports gratuits n'aurait pas mis le
revenu jeunes qui est un début de revenu
universel n'aurait pas mis l'accueil
inconditionnel des migrants et c'est
bien lire la constitution de la liste
mana vigneault qui est parti très très
très à gauche je laisserais brièvement
et après on avance dernièrement oui moi
je le répète
reprenons notre projet alors sur la
question du transport en commun dans une
partie de gratuité je tiens à le dire
c'est toute la france aujourd'hui qui se
pose la question et pas seulement des
listes de gauche se sont tous les
poulets toutes les villes qui veulent
aller sur des plantes climat air énergie
qui soit positif pour que massivement
les gens utilisent les transports en
commun et donc tous les leviers sont
utilisés analyser et la partie que l'on
nous non
c'est transports en commun gratuits le
samedi transports en commun pour les
moins de 26 ans je pense qu'on reprendra
le temps de l'expliquer mais c'est juste
qu'on est dans une caricature gratuité
partielle gratuité qui permettent de
faire évoluer le comportement des
nettoyants merci beaucoup
nicolas vous dis monsieur fagots en 2012
vous avez fait campagne contre le
mariage pour tous en tant que future
mère célébrer vous des mariages
homosexuels
oui c'est clair merci d'avoir fait
courant vous changé ou si vous monsieur
fagots c'est tant mieux je vous félicite
parce que je suis droit dans mes bottes
je ne change pas donc c'est bien on
écoute et changez vous allez chercher
supra toi monsieur buisson oui bon c'est
aux arguments est bon pour une fois aux
intéressés non mais c'est bien
votre rhétorique habré même rhétorique
aujourd'hui moi ce qui m'intéresse le
plus c'est dans ces besoins sont là qui
m'intéressent pas
autre question vous dites besançon
m'intéresse le plus monique vous demande
et ça rebondit sur une attaque dont eric
alauzet et l'auteur lors du dernier des
doigts monique vous demande monsieur
fagots élus mr habib trévoux besançon
alors encore une fois donc des
spéculations et des rumeurs ont circulé
tout le monde a fait référence à saône
et moi je vous le dit c'est une saison
qu'on a acheté avec mon épouse il ya
plus de douze ans maintenant quand
j'étais principal adjoint au collège de
soi donc je pense qu'on fait référence à
cela nous avons notre appartement à
besançon donc je vois soyez clair vous
vivez ou besançon et il ya des week-ends
on est sûr sur saône vous êtes
l'occident voyez donc voyez semblait là
dessus il n'ya pas il n'y a pas de
soucis chifa cours vous êtes réinstaller
sur la stone en 2007 pas de soucis mais
ces phrases aux messieurs fagots il
essaie de parler pour empêcher de parler
non mes genoux et y faire pousser les
inscrits sur les listes électorales à
saône en 2017
il est venu se réinscrire à besançon en
2019 au dernier moment donc je ne sais
pas quel continent rien ne m'empêcherait
notre objectif c'était d'être maire de
sony labou dit attention pour les
bisontins on peut en douter
ça c'est un peu mon argent
fonctionnement n'en attendais pas du
tout je veux dire je vais vous dire que
là dessus pour n'est qu'une gêne par
rapport à cela sûr que si